i i love you but i'm just gonna be that
[ __ ] right now
you look like you listen to elevator
music
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood we got a
bunch of people back on set today but we
got some surprises we got nikki blades
in the house hello thank you for joining
us again beautiful thank you for having
me i love your name it's just like rolls
off the tongue it's so easy to say it's
so original so good she sounds like a
mortal kombat character
oh yeah that's true i said she sounded
like a skater last night
but mortal kombat sounds way cooler
nikki blaze or rollerblades yeah that's
what she did that's what she meant
and then just was like a blade a blader
a blader but the roller bladers were not
very cool back in the day so i don't
think we're going to pa
darling sounds like a pin-up i [ __ ]
hate my name yeah it definitely sounds
like a part
it wasn't her choice it wasn't my choice
really so let's dig into this because
i've never heard that right i had a
stalker when i was like 20 21
and then like i had to get a restraining
order and everything because he was like
threatening to cut my breaks and [ __ ]
and found out where i lived and so i
just i just changed my name on facebook
and everything just really quick so that
no one like he can't find me he tried to
cut your brakes yeah right
imagine taking it
[Laughter]
joe from you yeah yeah
um
and then
so i was just on my computer changing my
name and i was like how would i change
my last name too and then i i just i had
my tv on and they said the word darling
i was like let's just change it really
quick and then that's when everything
took off and i'm stuck with this name oh
my god i've always hated it i just don't
think it fits me you're not a darling
yeah if you could change it what would
you change it to uh let's change it
right now what would you tim changed his
name back to chatham wrote soon
just a simple last name just gina o o
you know and kind of like it the
initials would have been go like it
would have i loved it
why
can't you now your initials are gd
goddammit
i think it's too late now especially now
that i'm gonna be on well gina darling
it doesn't sound like it sounds like a
pin-up to me in my head but it goes with
i don't know i just i guess because it's
associated with you it made the name
good like you know what i mean this was
during like go-go dancing years so
everyone had their aliases and stuff
yeah and like it worked for that because
it was like a cute girly like dancer
name
but now i'm like i don't really like it
you're like a stripper but you can't get
rid of your stripper name exactly
like i so i don't i don't know if i can
handle rebranding right now because
everyone knows me as that and i'm about
to hit tv and well by the time this
episode comes out i'm on and it's just
changed your name to a symbol like
prince
[Laughter]
i did not get to jess but we also have
her on board and the only reason i
wanted to delve more into that story was
because i didn't i didn't know that
about you and the game that we're
playing today is called
we're not really strangers
yeah thank you
she was a master of segways so much
um
and we're playing that game and it's all
about digging deeper into our like who
you are as a person and how things came
about and maybe things that we didn't
know about each other will come to the
surface and since nikki blitz has been
with us quite a few episodes i thought
it was time to dig deep in with her
you're trying to dig deep
dig deep in that into making blades well
wow yes what's in there i don't know
we'll find out we're going to find out
i just flirt with everybody on this show
a lot of eye contact
there's a lot of chemistry in this group
i feel like i feel flirty i know i think
my nipples are getting harder
whenever nicki is here whenever nicholas
or my back starts arching
everybody
for that
[Laughter]
before we get started though i did want
to shout out we're not really strangers
they have a card game you can actually
play the physical card game with your
friends to get conversations going or
they have they have different decks too
where you can work with your partners
so we're not sponsored by them at all
but i just love their game so much they
just released one called the
self-reflecting game you play by
yourself the boxes you play by yourself
oh that feels
deep yeah you really want to cry so like
it's it's so cute it comes in a box
that's like like it looks like a mirror
it's so pretty
it's so pretty it's because it's wood
yeah i think you should play that and
get get deeper in it
just look at it
so pretty
when you talk about shadow work that's a
great game for delving into shadow
shadow work is when you work on the
parts of you that you don't really like
to look at like where you kind of avoid
addressing those parts but it makes you
who you are and it makes you a full
person and you have to embrace both
parts because they they make you can't
have the good without the bad well you
better turn this sound professional even
i know put it on they're very popular
they're all jealous yeah we have another
guest coming in so she's trying to keep
yes
mostly based off looks like first
impressions
what did you think about each other and
we're gonna rotate around so we'll start
with me i guess because i'm holding the
phone um everyone can answer feel free
to shout it out there's no order but
make an assumption about me
based off of
this
i know you too well i know right about
you what you i guess nikki blades can
just like right now i know i'm trying to
say you assume something make an answer
there's things you assume about her
you're hella nice just like sweet like
the type of person that may be too sweet
like you look so
nice that maybe you can get taken
advantage of because you look like
really sweet all the time like anybody
like you're probably nice to everybody
no matter who they are i was going to
make a joke about like oh good my
devices are working but then like you
hit like like actually
sorry
she was like
yeah we're gonna make mascara run today
oh lord not these lashes yeah when i
first are we all answering for you
yeah
uh the first time at you they said that
or you said or something that said that
you were a comedian and the first thing
i that popped into my head was
oh that [ __ ] has been through some [ __ ]
this is comedian the nice and the dark
behind the eyes yeah yeah because you
gotta go through some [ __ ] to become a
stand-up comedian like not even just
like youtube or whatever but stand up
like this [ __ ] has been through it you
know what's funny too is like when i got
into stand-up it didn't feel like a big
deal it wasn't like a like everyone i
told i was like oh yeah i'm doing
stand-up now they're like oh my god like
how do you get the balls like for it to
be so natural i think also
says something yeah i was like no this
is just where
it's gotta go out it's gonna go out to
yeah we're gonna put this darkness in
the world
i'm gonna share this yeah i'm not scared
of many things but stand up is one of
the things that i'm most terrified of if
i go up there and no one left my joke
i'm off in myself and the boundaries oh
my god immediately
you just have to joke about how no one's
laughing at your jokes yeah right
i don't tell them going to the back of
the building right now i'm allowed to
make this joke by the way [ __ ] you guys
you guys
you're not part of this game this is
intimate okay we're just getting a peek
at our
intimate conversations
jess jessica this is this is for you yes
so everyone answers this yeah okay
whoever wants to or somebody who wants
to okay what about me intrigues you
you better have some sort of answer but
you live on well the thing well you did
and you still kind of do you live on the
other side of life the life that i've
always wondered like what if i did
you know college
and and and like
yeah what if i did a college and i did a
day job or not a day job but like a
career like a professional career and
sometimes i like think to myself like
what's it like on the other side and you
are very interesting because you've done
that but you've been on our side too
so you know both worlds because people
always tell me like gina i'm you know
i'm so jealous of you you get to do
whatever you want i'm like yeah well you
have life
[ __ ] [ __ ] insurance you know
so i'm always so like you could have
life insurance gina
i don't want to pay like 40 bucks
you're paying for it either way never
mind we'll talk about that later see i
don't know that question when you get
married you'll
yeah for me i'm always wondering what
you're thinking like i look at you and
i'm wondering what's going on i hear
that a lot in your mind because i i find
you very interesting the way you think
the way you analyze things uh we were
just having a conversation like i love
talking to you i feel like the
conversation with you is so
the range we could talk about basic [ __ ]
like talking about hooking up with
someone to sitting and talking about
numbers and finances and and future
plans so for you it's like i don't i
haven't explored all of you yet yeah
that's really interesting to me that
there's a lot of parts that we don't
know so i love that yeah i would love to
have conversations with you
that's that's kind of the same thing i
was gonna say is there's always like
something new that pops up that i'm like
you know i think like i kind of get how
you operate and how your brain works but
then like you'll say something that
surprises me all the time where it's
like i didn't know you'd be into that
like yeah like when i found out you were
like listen to punk rock bands i was
like oh like i just didn't
like i i because i didn't know that you
i we would have been friends in high
school probably yeah yeah yeah
i also for the longest time because joe
told me about this in the past sorry for
saying his name
um it's fine and we're first i don't
know
um i don't have any issue with joe okay
um i'm so i i really want to meet your
friends back home because he told me how
like or you also talk about how you guys
used to go [ __ ] clubbing and dive
bars and you were a cheerleader and all
that you are a cheerleader yes this is
something true i heard she really
literally never would have gotten again
yeah
right
what the [ __ ]
i mean don't i know why you're confused
i had the bombshell bro you remembered
do you feel like when i think of you as
a cheerleader i feel like it's like an
all black outfit you have black hair and
a lot of eyeliner
for some reason
bring it on like that one yeah yeah and
i want to meet your friends so bad and
hear all these stories and see how
you're all like how you're looking
around them and stuff well you can
always come to texas
yeehaw all right blades all right this
one's for you okay what do you think i'm
most likely to splurge on oh as well oh
based on just looking at me okay huh
everything about you looks expensive
exactly anything you put on your body
i was like
because your outfit
i'm like an excess some sort of
accessory right now i'm like a purse
like a i picture like like a chanel bag
or something i don't know a lot about
purses but something expensive yeah yeah
a birkin
self-care that's a lot self-care but not
only just on the outside but on the
inside um i feel like because i know you
and i know you're real good with your
money mm-hmm um and i know you don't
just splurge into this this is based off
of the look
yeah self-care like you you are
you're so pretty yeah
like if you ever like you the first time
i saw you on camera i was like i just
know she smells good yeah you know like
i know she smells good yeah
yeah so like everything from tiptoe you
know like
it's it's just beautiful and you put
work into it and you put love and money
into it like i can thank you yeah you
don't give me dusty [ __ ] fine yeah i'm
getting dusty
that's
part of like the mask yeah because i
don't splurge my money on like purses
it's like this was on sale like
everything i have i've uh i've kind of
always been raised to look a certain way
but knowing that you don't have to spend
money to do it yes and people that are
just buying a lot of expensive things
you're probably distracting others from
what's really going on dad used to tell
me like if a guy is paying attention to
your shoes and that's the only thing
he's looking at he's missing the best
part i guess you know what it is is your
smile like you you radiate confidence
and to me you look like a person that
says i deserve this like and with no
like oh is it too expensive like should
i i don't know this is like waste of
money like it's just like no i deserve
this part of my life like it's it's just
like you own that like thank you that
confidence personality was crazy is i
struggle with that like buying things
that i deserve or or
there was like this idea of like the
supermodel for me i idolized 90
supermodels and there was something so
beautiful about them and it wasn't the
designer outfits they were wearing
there's something about being able to
wash off all your makeup and still feel
beautiful and there's something
expensive about that yeah there's always
like these little things and the more
natural you are and the less effort you
put in it's uh like a classier look
right so i've tried to adopt those
tricks into into my life so when i go to
certain places i'm not threatened by the
ysl bag or the chanel bag and i know
that i understand why you have it it's
beautiful but i want to look like i have
it
and not need it right exactly so like
you you'd have something simple that
just that compliments you and maybe it's
expensive maybe it's not right it looks
classy it looks exciting and pulling
back that's one thing i had to learn how
to do is pull back because i mean i love
i love the glitter and bright and the
lashes and everything is big you know
sexy boobs out you know legs and it was
learning how to like dial it back yeah i
had to really do that pull it back pull
it back pull it back so i appreciate
that because that's the goal like
everything you guys described is like
the goal so that means that it's working
yay
okay do you think i was popular in
school explain yes i know you well
but just by looking at you i would say
yes really yeah because there's
something about you that's so attractive
it's not just like your look like you
have a quality that makes me want to go
towards you like it's magnetic so for me
because i wasn't popular in school and i
looked at you i'm like oh my god you
look so nice and fun and funny and like
a guy's girl and everybody probably
would just like you
by looking at you i would have thought
like looking at you now because i've
seen your actual high school pictures
but like looking at you now i would have
thought you were more of like the
rebellious girl that i might not have
seen a lot of so i wouldn't necessarily
say popular girl but like you are like
someone that everyone's attracted to and
like they it's like you're unattainable
almost because you're like elusive like
you are sometimes there like leaning up
in the [ __ ] locker or you're like in
the bleach by the under the bleachers
smoking cigarettes or something
everybody's like
like you're badass but like
too mysterious to be the popular
cheerleader chick
popular is a different thing from liked
or wanted for me i think it's the same
thing like you would be the elusive
[ __ ] cloud of smoke in the corner or
like you're too cool for the popular
people even it's more interesting than
the the popular like keeps a close
circle and you can't get in
because she'll crush you like a
cockroach so uh growing up in the bay i
was actually a nerd and i got bullied a
lot like i had crooked teeth pimples it
was gross
um all the way till freshman year and
then sophomore year is when i moved to
socal
into a very less diverse uh school
because in the bay like every like
every race every everything like we were
a huge school we were just you know
football champions stuff we were huge
and then i'm moving to like a smaller
all chinese school right like i swear to
god there was one white guy two black
guys that's it like yeah and then when i
first moved here um it was like i i was
i was a goth kid
oh
kid and i used to be that kid with like
the chain wallet and the knife in school
and stuff like that oh we would have
been friends yeah
so see i later on found out like during
senior year i was always known like the
kids all knew who i was the popular
girls who knew who i was but um in the
school in my city they have like a they
have like these little sororities and
fraternities like official ones in
school it's really weird in high school
yeah like they rush and they have bigs
and littles and they're like oh we want
you to join us and i'm like no
no right um so and i hung out with the
nerds i played video games yeah so
apparently i was always known and then
my friend that i'm still friends with
till the day she's like the girls in the
sororities and stuff
were scared of you yes you know that's
exactly what i mean so i just i i guess
they knew who i was i think we nailed it
basically yeah
because again i didn't know any of the
other stuff and i'm like i'm just
judging off of right now and today i'm
like i feel like everybody would want to
hang out with you they would but they're
scared yeah and that's like everybody's
definition of
my second week i remember okay so the
first day of school uh i
became friends with this girl who
introduced me to this guy who i dated
for a month there and he we moved into
lockers together because you know high
school your locker is your apartment gag
but his ex-girlfriend that broke up with
him a week ago was two lockers down oh
[ __ ] yeah so then for the first like two
weeks of school her friends kept on
trying to like message me on aim he's
like who the [ __ ] are you blah blah and
then one day i had a really bad day and
i told her friend i was like if my name
comes out of her [ __ ] mouth again i'm
gonna break her yeah she was like this
tiny little asian girl and then so it
doesn't really
well the next day she's like oh i just
want to be friends i'm like yeah
yeah you do so it doesn't really help my
reputation that i threatened to beat up
a girl two weeks in but what will help
your reputation is by listening to
whatever we're about to tell you to go
listen to and using the codes we tell
you to use
to enhance your life you know treat
yourself buy upgrade your lifestyle buy
it all right everyone listen up we've
got some new products from manscaped
they've launched their ultra premium
collection and now they're moving above
the waistline and you know how important
it is to have a grooming routine
personally i pick two days out of the
week i do a full shower with a scrub
body scrub shave everything head to toe
do all my hair stuff at once so i think
this would be great if you've got
manscaped for your boyfriend make him do
his little two days a week grooming
routine get on the same page so you guys
can have fun at the same time and also
be hairless at the same time everyone's
familiar with the lawnmower 4.0 which is
the best in the business for trimming
below the waist but now you can enhance
your grooming routine with the ultra
premium collection this package includes
four products and a gift listen up
manscaped premium deodorant okay
hydrating body spray kind of like a
lotion but more like a spray then
they've got body wash infused with aloe
vera and sea salt and two in one shampoo
and conditioner infused with sea kelp
and coconut water plus a free gift which
is a three pack set of lip balm to keep
those lips feeling moist all of these
products are cruelty free paraben free
vegan friendly and dye free the best
ingredients with zero compromise help
your guy join the 4 million men
worldwide who look great and smell great
thanks to manscaped by going to
manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping with the code mood that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
mood at manscape.com
the only smell you'll want on him in a
bottle thanks to manscape all right guys
sometimes in order to go green you have
to get blue blue land that is and blue
land was founded on the belief that a
cleaner planet starts by eliminating
plastic waste while creating powerful
effective cleaners for your entire home
i'm such a huge fan of blue land it's so
freaking cute and so eco-friendly
because blue land's idea is super simple
and beautiful you buy the bottle just
once and you refill it forever no more
plastic waste and the only thing that
you need to discard is your outdated
idea that eco-friendly products are more
expensive and less effective because
that's just not true with blue land all
you have to do is just fill blue lands
beautiful instagramable bottles with
warm water you pop in one of the hand
soap or spray cleaner tablets you watch
it fizzle away and within minutes you
have powerful cleaning products in the
most incredible sense such as iris agave
perion lemon and lavender eucalyptus and
they smell amazing from their
best-selling cleaning essentials kits to
their hand soap duo and plastic free
laundry and dishwasher tablets which by
the way oh my god they make my laundry
smell amazing my dishes come out super
clean i'm such a huge fan blue land has
something for every inch of your home
and back by popular demand is blue
land's toilet tablet cleaner you should
get it before it sells out again because
it's high quality stuff you guys blue
lands stunning high quality forever
bottles just start at 10 when you buy a
kit and are meant to be reused forever
with money-saving refill tablets that
start at just two dollars try blue land
today you'll love it and the planet will
thank you right now you can get fifteen
percent off your first order when you go
to blueland.com
big mood that's 15 off your first order
of any products blueland.com big mood
don't forget blueland.com
big mood okay did you buy it you broke
[ __ ] okay
let me go
to the next level what were you like in
high school oh
conflicted because i went to a super
super small school that
i just did not fit in
i looked different i was different there
was nobody like me and we didn't have
like jocks nerds and others it was very
mushed together because everybody i
graduated with like less than a hundred
people so yeah me too yeah so so for me
i wasn't
i was great at sports but i was fighting
all the time just to find a place like
the girls didn't like me or the guys
were scared of my family well the guys
were terrified of my dad my dad made
sure everybody stayed away but like even
like the politics it's a lot of small
town politics and being you know
essentially like the broke brown girl at
school that everybody like everybody
knew
so
i wasn't popular i had my close friends
maybe like two or three one ended up
being my brother-in-law and i'm related
i'm like i'm like related to them now
yeah they're my brother-in-laws but my
best friends like in high school you
would look at them and be like i
don't get it but then you would get it
if you knew me and i just yeah because i
was in art for four years i was in band
i was an athlete i wanted to like model
i was out there super goofy like i
always got compared to like nick cannon
back when he was on all that
back in that day like that's how i was
so i was just
really awkward for a while but i
probably wasn't it just was the people i
was around yeah i i looked the same
never mind
i looked
better
i never really changed since like my
junior year of high school i've lost
i've like looked this way but people
didn't find me attractive
it just wasn't what was attractive yeah
yeah but i didn't want to get that then
i went to college and i was like i knew
i wasn't ugly yeah you know no it's just
weird
it's this weird perception because well
back then we talked about this on a
different episode like you watch tv and
it's like the beautiful is like white
blonde hair blue eyes and so i didn't
think i was like i don't i don't think i
was i'm attractive but i really haven't
changed either since high school and
then i was treated so differently
afterwards and then i saw like kind of
the change in
mainstream media of like i remember
looking at nicole scherzinger because
the pussycat
and i would look and i'd look in the
mirror and i'm like
i'm
i kind of look like her and i'm like i
don't understand but i wanted attention
i didn't i need i wanted attention i
needed validation it was it was really
hard high school was like my mom had to
remind me like daily that it's going to
be okay i would never go back to high
school never go back i did not i didn't
enjoy my high school experience at all
college though oh my god i didn't i
didn't do one of those i didn't like
college yeah i did i mean when i was a
college athlete and it was the epitome
of being like a badass on campus like
nikki blade started in college and it
was on the softball field and it's like
my confidence lives in that space yeah
and whenever i'm feeling down i'm like
what would that nicki do and i'd be like
never mind she would probably punch
somebody and then be like
make out with somebody else i don't know
i was really like you couldn't tell me
you were feeling yourself but now i'm
like balanced out i'm like i'm in a nice
balance now punch me it's very okay
later
i can't help it whenever she's i'm
straight as [ __ ] but when nikki's around
she's like yeah but i'm not so that's
probably what's
happening to
moving on um how many speeding tickets
do you think i've gotten in my life and
again this is just looking at you yeah
you look like you drive under the speed
that's what i'm saying
you look like you drive a prius with a
cat in the passenger seat and like the
windows are down and you're just like
dude
she got those eyelashes headlights like
yeah yeah
you look like i'm like a phoebe yeah
you're a phoebe you look like you don't
use your turn signal
do you know what i mean like you look
like you're in the far left lane like
i'm just driving today and now i'm in
there
you're the ones we honk at yes
you look like you do this i'm so sorry
yeah that's so funny i wish you could i
wish steve was here so you could tell
you drive like a goddamn bat
really
i fear for my life but that's why like
just looking at you especially you have
the little braids in your hair and you
have like a knit top but you know what's
funny is i'm still singing and doing
like but i'm just driving 90 per hour
you're not leaving out of trouble but
i'm like it's a beautiful day
everyone's dying in the back there's
explosions yeah and i pause sometimes
like i'll be like something in the hey
[ __ ]
she moves
i've never been in a car [ __ ] i would
never guess why don't get in the car
holy crap so you're the one honking at
us yeah i'm like but it's funny because
i get kind of like irritated when like
passengers get scared i'm like i got you
like what i've never been in an accident
why you being so dramatic yeah
you scared me stop it
i've never been in an accident before
i'm like the past performance it doesn't
reflect future
options my driving record says i get
great insurance prices
why is insurance trust me then why does
insurance
yeah i think it's so funny when drivers
get upset that the passengers are scared
oh i hate it we're all the girls i hate
it
but yeah when i look at you it's like
right now in this look i would have
never thought that you would be like
going above 35. so i had a moment of
enlightenment as a los angeles driver i
used to go on tour and i would rent cars
in every city that i go to and i would
just get pissed at all the drivers and
then i remember my friends telling me
you're you know like when you're young
or when people tell you you're a
terrible driver you're like no i'm not
yeah you never accept it and then one
day i think i was in atlanta and i was
driving and then
my my friends in the car were like dude
and then i had a moment of like what the
[ __ ] up with all these drivers in
every city and then i was like oh
maybe it is i you are that driver in
that city yeah so i was like oh so now
like if i hadn't gotten there yet yeah
yeah
so my driving self-awareness
i still think people can't drive for
[ __ ]
i think i'm a better driver than you um
just based off of looking i mean again
surface level yeah i'm going to just
assume that about myself that i look
like i drive better than you do i'm baby
driver that's why i tell steve i'm like
if i have music on and i'm singing to it
i'm baby driver i can weave in and out
and we'll get there on time and
no one's going to get scathed yeah the
one the one rule i had was
after learning how to drive better is my
passenger i always make sure their head
never bobs yeah break or take off oh one
thing i won't consider
me is if people get too close to the
person in front of i always leave a lot
of padding in between me and the person
in front of me i get mad if they're
driving slow but i will leave padding i
don't like when people tailgate because
i've been in accidents before well i'm
not driving yeah and it they hit the
person in front and it's it's
traumatizing yeah when steve gets too
close i'm like see you get mad at me but
like you're driving so far closer
but i loved again because of your outfit
right like i love that i look like i
look really again you look really really
nice i think i like that flowers painted
on the side of your car oh yeah i do
drive a hybrid not a prius though it's a
honda yeah i don't know
jessica
yeah they make me angry angry all right
so do you think i fall in love easily
why or why not no no no no just lawful
looking at you right no no why you look
like you someone have to prove
themselves to you first you look picky
yeah which isn't bad yeah it's not bad
if you're following me no is that
because you know me no knowing you what
do i look like knowing you i'm like if
you i know that if the reason you're not
having sex with people is because you'll
develop feelings too fast so i know that
like
because knowing you that you might fall
in love
quicker than usual if a physical thing
happens but looking at you right you
look picky like you look like why
what about me looks picky i would say
just
your resting face okay you're you're
arrested you're you're wrestling you're
gonna have to earn your you like
your smile looks like you have to work
for it yeah it doesn't look like it's
naturally oh you don't look like you're
always smiling naturally but like your
resting face makes me assume that i'm
gonna have to work to try to make you
smile like you're not just gonna give it
yeah like you're not one of those people
that walk by strangers be like like you
don't get any of those for free yeah
again just surface people and not
knowing you yeah that's me though
because i would have but i would have
never known that you fall in love easily
because i don't know you like that yet
so for me i hearing that i'm like oh
oh that's interesting now i want to know
more but again just based off of looks
and be like nah
she ain't just falling for no [ __ ]
like you better bring your a game
everything i think that is true but like
i when the guys have their a game then i
fall fast you know what i mean yeah it's
not like any tom dick or harry but like
when they're
really good at it
but yeah but i'm like gross
things don't know
what compliment
do you think i hear the most
damn
[Laughter]
yeah
just ruin my credit i don't care
let's take it here's the keys have my
kids this whatever that's the one i hear
the most
looking at you obviously your appearance
you're beautiful thank you but i'm after
interacting with you i'm like wow your
personality your personality really
shines like you're you can hold yourself
you're really good at conversation like
you're just someone that i would want to
be around all the time no you're so much
more than your looks you know yeah
you're like that's just scratching the
surface because i think i've seen you
since my go-go dancing days i always
know the name nikki blaze damn like i
was pretty
but then meeting you i'm like she's
funny she's intelligent you know she has
her [ __ ] together thank you and that
just makes you from like a 10 to like a
15. when you get picked on growing up
you develop a personality
i was like the looks came later yeah the
personality was first yeah i appreciate
that i know i know what i look like what
compliment do you get the most what on
like first meeting me or like yeah like
maybe just the one you like what do you
hear the most the one that sticks with
me is the personality one okay because
that means more to you yeah that means
more i mean the the looks one i became a
model so i
that's part of the work yeah it's
probably more critical of the like
whatever the physical those just like
bounce off of you right yeah yeah
because i feel like you probably get 10
000 damn girls all day long and then
you're but you become numb to it it's
almost like something you have to have
on your resume in order to even get in
that field so it's like yeah you know
yeah it's the it's part of the standard
yeah like those don't sit with me the
way that like
getting to know you're actually really
funny um i think i love when people
realize how nice i am
yeah you know like i like that part if
you can see that i like love you and i
care about you that i love that
compliment and the funny one whenever
somebody says like you know you're
actually pretty funny right yeah yeah
because that's where i started like i
always crack jokes i was always the
goofy one that was the deflection thing
it's like that's what i got in my bag
yeah i mean i know you're not gonna be
attracted to me but i just always like
that was my way to get attention i grew
up around like a little lot of people
and i'm the crybaby of the family me too
so sensitive like i am so sensitive but
i was one they were like yo
nicole is awkward like i just looked
different than everybody else but i
loved being like big in the room like i
wanted to like to dance or whatever
everything with like movement so and
being funny or making accents and just
dancing goofy like i loved doing that so
that's how i got attention and then
later i was like oh i look a certain way
but i always wanted that to shine more
than the way that i looked so i
appreciate that yeah thank you and i
keep locking your phone my bad oh that's
okay just fall it does as a model do you
ever like
i don't know how to say that sound like
a douchebag but like modeling-wise
growing up and whenever people tell me
i'm ugly i'm like okay oh yeah
is sensitive right nicole is sensitive
nicole is the one that gets her feelings
hurt nicole is the one that feels ugly
she
feels like you don't belong
but nikki because i created like i
created nikki it's always been me but
that's the person i've wanted to be but
i know what happens when i walk in the
room because i've also trained myself to
to command a room when i walk into a
space uh if i want to be nice and bubbly
and fun like i know how to walk into
that uh where if i want all eyes on me
and just to be standing there and to
look regal or to look like whoa who is
that i've you know
yeah i know what to do there's a walk
there's a presence there's a confidence
there's there's a way you hold yourself
so people try to say like i'm not pretty
i'll be like look i know some days i'm
not preaching maybe not
everyone else you join the minority
party
but you know there's days where i'm like
because we again we're in front of the
camera so much i'm like you can't tell
me [ __ ] like [ __ ] i already know the
flaws that i have yeah i already know
what you would want me to fix yeah dude
especially as a youtuber where you're
editing your yeah yeah yeah you're
editing yourself all day like you heard
it all so that's why i'm like look
you may not like how i look but i ended
up getting paid for talking so i can do
both like i get paid now to be on the
radio also i can do a swimsuit
i could talk on the radio in a swimsuit
you would never know because i got a
photo shoot
but that's like the power you hold where
you can be like man that's all right
it's okay yeah that's how i feel about
all my girls in entertainment you know
like in entertainment you have to you do
look a certain way and you look nice on
camera and people like you guys get
compliment all the time so every time i
see comments of like oh you're ugly
whatever i'm like
yeah
okay yeah
it's just the person on the other side
yeah
i mean you could be ugly to that person
that doesn't have anything to do with
the general public
let's be real when was the last time you
actually looked at somebody and called
them ugly and it was just based off
their looks the only time i've ever
thought somebody was really ugly is your
personality
true that's so true if you go and think
people are ugly like you're ugly yeah
because i look at people i'm like i i
wouldn't be like there's there's so much
so many people yeah i don't think i've
looked at someone like damn that's
really true yeah i've never thought that
adjective unless the personality you
don't like
yeah like you're ugly inside and outside
yeah
okay here we go
do you think i ever checked an ex's
phone for evidence
hell yeah
while they're an x or where they're not
an x yet i think while dating okay you
look like
you've taken the phone while they're
sleeping lifted and i like lifted up
their eyelids so that you can scan the
retinas and then like but they're
probably drugged up on nyquil because
you don't like spike there you are a
detective digging ass yeah and we
actually just had this in our girl chat
though
you posted something it was like someone
else posted like they did they [ __ ] up
they like called their boyfriend out
because they the boyfriend said they
were going to bed and then they saw they
were active on instagram so they
immediately screenshot it and like call
them out and then they realized that it
was active 20 minutes ago yeah yeah and
now you're at night you have to erase
everything before they see that you're
crazy yeah so i've actually only looked
at a guy that i'm dating phone me uh
for
two guys that i've dated and i was right
both times
because the gut knows the gut knows you
know yeah the guy is when he got hoes if
you feel like you want to just don't but
then also still go ahead and like end it
probably exactly yeah that's what i said
is that like because i did that i like
looked through their phone and i don't
like it you're gonna find you find it
yeah so now i'm like you know if i ever
feel like i have to check through my
partner's phone it's just not meant to
be yeah i won't check it anymore i'll
never do that again but it's just not
meant to be there's a voice inside of me
that's like they are one thousand
percent right you've got to be better
than that and then the other side of me
is like [ __ ] you gonna check his phone
it's a battle every time every time but
it's almost to prove to yourself that
you're not crazy though yeah because
it's like until you have that evidence
it's like am i am i crazy yeah is he not
lying to me is he telling the truth and
i'm just like making [ __ ] up and then
you get that evidence and it's
validating but now you're pissed because
it hurts right you actually found it
yeah
like
but then when you look and there's
nothing there then you're like what and
now it's almost like you have to find
something like i already took this step
i must find something no it's more like
there's nothing no one wants my man
really
[Applause]
i'm kidding but the the first time i
ever did that was uh my i was 19 20
years old or something and i was dating
this guy for two years and i was right
there was four different women
there was a text to his friend while he
was in vegas like you guys got condoms
like i was right oh my god that makes my
own yeah that makes the pits come back
that was my first serious you know and
that
affected me for a long time yeah you
know
um so i did that and then i was right
you know and then i've only had to do it
one other time i was also right but then
other than that
i
never felt like i had to do that again
with my other relationships um
how do you guys feel about because uh
stacy preaches this a lot she's like
keep your peace don't look at the phone
if it's if it's meant to
show up and and
whatever it will show up and you'll find
out eventually how do you feel about
that because for me i'm like
no if i even have those thoughts or
feelings one we got to talk about it i
got to tell my partner immediately and
if i feel like they're like if i feel in
any way that they're lying to me or
gaslighted me then it just shouldn't
because there's obviously trust issues
there's some sort of trust issue going
on so why even be in that yeah or the
thing on tick tock is not rather keep my
peace i'd rather eat today so i'm not
gonna look at his phone like well i
never understood that you know no that's
not good or like
says um don't go looking or else you're
gonna find something that's more true
that's true so what is what is that if
you go looking you will find something
it's just like you're going to find your
answer regardless i think the root of
that saying is that
you've now found an answer the fact that
you're looking you have trust issues
i think a lot of people don't use that
saying correctly because like if you go
looking you're going to find evidence
the thing is if you go looking you're
going to make a reason you're going to
find whatever you want to find because
now you've you're trying to justify your
feelings but
it means you're already feeling that
you're already feeling it
if your partner isn't something that
makes you feel
like you can't trust them or like
they're they're going to cheat on you if
they go to vegas you know then that's
either you have to work out your own
trauma from the past from a partner that
cheated on you sure or this partner is
not
the most trustworthy yeah and and i
think you just hit a real important
point that we never talk about is like
why do you feel that way because again
there are times where you're the toxic
person yeah they're not and you have to
really face like is it me or are they
actually giving me the science that
they're trying to say ninety percent of
the time it's probably their shady and
that's why your gut is like right like
because i fully believe that we have
yeah there's women
and i don't want anyone to think like oh
i'm crazy no no no trust me let it go no
trust your gut one thousand percent but
then that makes you there's times where
are you reacting to therapy
yes there's a chance that it could be
just [ __ ] that [ __ ] crazy but
probably if the phantom is turned over
if you're noticing he's out more if the
likes on instagram like there's so many
if he goes like this yeah and then he
locks his phone yeah there's how there
you'd be happy without involving your
stuff yeah you're not a lot of laughing
smiling yet so meme you're laughing at a
meme without me and that is why i am
still singing my
who the [ __ ] making you smile today if i
ask you are you having a good day and
you say yes and i'll be like why i'm not
there
i'm like oh good you should be having a
terrible day and they're they're the
toxic ones they're the talking about
i always tell my men like either you're
going to be with me or you're going to
be with jesus make a decision i don't
know no one else but you know what
but you know what these toxic ass men
love some crazy because they keep coming
back they ain't one that won't come back
what's up i know i saw your texting
you know what i'm saying
it's bad they're they're they're the
worst they're they're the dumb ones
crazy i would not come back to me you
should i wouldn't date me back then
hell no i am crazy
because they they go do i want crazy or
boring it's like yeah you're always
going to lean a little bit and then you
need to kind of toxic trees yeah then
you become boring and they're like this
is not what i signed up for i'm gonna go
like pictures on instagram yeah she
reads i gotta go straight
today
what subject do you think i thrived at
in school and did i fail any
you didn't feel [ __ ] but this is just
based on you looking like just based off
of looking at you i'm really trying to
act like i don't know anything about you
and just look at you it's the outfit the
outfit is really
thrilling
it's very hippy-dippy you look like you
loved science though there's something
about me that makes me think you are
into astrology and just
the universe i love
you look like the art girl that wore
um
the maxi denim skirt you get art
the maxi denim skirt with a frizzy long
hair or you look like yeah in art class
you like a pottery you look like i did
take ceramics yeah my grandpa taught the
class apparently i keep saying all these
things wrong and i get you know the
batteries
that's right she said i took ceramics i
was
it's it's a different name it's a
pottery wheel it's ceramic
yeah it's the same thing
you don't have to pot you can you can do
a hand made
too but the pottery wheel is there if
you want and what did you fail in math
[Music]
you look like you failed math
again your outfit is really throwing me
off i know i know the braids it's the
little freaking thing
don't look good
like you aren't good at math like you're
too pretty to be like better at math
than me
my career is in math but again just
looking at yeah i'm trying to act as
thought
and that's what makes you amazing
really because you look like you love
horses
[Applause]
changing immediately after this
she's like all right we're never wearing
this outfit again
that would be the perfect poker outfit
you're right if i was to just sit at the
table look at him like she don't know
where it
is she just turned 21 look at this
no i love that because yeah that makes
they will never expect never to know
anything about odds or ratios or
anything i should wear this outfit you
should get in the hair and then oh yeah
the hair
she's too innocent so no math
yeah and just hold your cards all weird
like how do i
what is this what does the a mean
what if you have two a's
is that good
uh anyway uh when you are thinking about
shopping for your next outfit maybe
check out our sponsor if they sell that
or wear a cute outfit to check out our
sponsor
whatever we're talking about go buy it
figure that out figure it out i said it
perfectly i saw what i said we're still
good at this fanduel sportsbook is an
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56 to celebrate new customers can
bet five dollars to win 280 dollars in
cash on either team to win when you use
promo code big mood when registering
that's right you'll get your winnings in
cold hard cash because we know cash is
always better than quote unquote free
bets there's no better place to bet
super bowl 56 than fanduel sportsbook
they got promotions for new and existing
customers they've got same game parlays
where you can combine small bets for
bigger wins and there's tons of super
bowl props and more personally i gotta
bet for the rams i usually don't bet on
my dad's team to win but coming from los
angeles living there my entire adult
life i gotta root for la to win and it's
in la this year and eminem is playing in
the su you don't need to know that i'm
also betting on eminem i wish i could
you can't do that don't try to do that
on fanduel they won't let you but if i
could i would i guess i'll just stick to
betting for the rams i do love watching
super bowl no matter what just two teams
that have been fighting all season for
the big win duking it out well i get to
eat appetizers and drink drinks with my
friends it's just an all-around good
time and betting on it makes it even
more fun so don't miss your chance to
turn five dollars into 280 in cash
download the fanduel sportsbook app and
use promo code big mood to make every
moment more this super bowl again promo
code big mood exclusively on fanduel
sportsbook disclaimer you must be 21 and
over and present arizona colorado
connecticut iowa illinois indiana
michigan new jersey pennsylvania
tennessee virginia or west virginia new
years only ten dollars first deposit
required much wager and designated offer
market max bonus 150 bonus for tennessee
users were filled in site credit within
72 hours tennessee site credit expires
14 days after receipt restriction
supplies see full terms at sportsbook
panel.com gambling problem call 100
gambler or visit fanduel.com rg in
colorado iowa michigan new jersey
pennsylvania illinois in virginia 1 800
next step or text next step to 53342 in
arizona
887-8977 or visit ccpg.org chat in
connecticut 1-809 with it in indiana
tennessee redline
revolution 1-800-889-9789 2022 this year
prioritize you first with beam's premium
cbd products for sleep personally i've
been working a lot of hours lately i've
been having some trouble sleeping
because not only is my brain geared up
from having to work so much but i'll be
drinking extra coffee and dealing with
emails and stuff will give me some
anxiety so by the end of the night i'm
still kind of too wired to sleep and i
do need something to kind of help me
wind down beam is the world's most
innovative functional wellness brand and
today our listeners get a special
discount on beam's sleep product the
dream powder their best-selling healthy
hot cocoa it contains natural sleep
promoting ingredients triple lab tested
with no thc and you wake up refreshed
here's why it works our bodies have an
endocannabinoid system or a highway of
communication between the brain and the
body specifically designed to work with
cannabinoids which is why cbd has taken
over the wellness world recently and
beam's nano cbd dramatically increases
your body's ability to absorb cbd making
their products the most effective in the
wellness space just mix dream powder
into hot water or milk stir and enjoy
before bedtime for a limited time get
twenty dollars off seventy five dollars
or more when you go to beam organics dot
com slash big mood and use our code big
mood at checkout that's beam b e a m
organics dot com slash big mood and use
code big mood for 20 off make 2022 the
year of you with beam okay and we're
back and we're ready to find out more
about these people i love this game so
much it's strange my favorite
gina actually has the physical card game
that we're going to play call me back
different i want to have different cards
for that yeah
you have to play more and i'm re
i'm really trying to act like i know
nothing i'm like yeah i'm going to be a
judge
i'm going to be a judgy ass [ __ ] right
now and just be
looking and just trying to read you
right we should do an episode like that
one day where we just bring a random
person
oh god playing games just lavender oh an
actual stranger
that should be interesting we are really
strangers
as a child what do you think i want it
to be when i grow up
picture little child me what do you
think i would want to be when i grow up
i think you blonde though even though
that's not true but like i was blind
when i was a baby and then it turned
brown and then i dyed it blonde why did
the first thing that popped into my head
is a teacher that's what i thought too
like teacher i for some reason i didn't
see you with glasses and just like t i
don't know i just yeah you just look
look teacher literally you can't do that
little you looks nice
and like you want to help the world
like you want to help like you want to
you're innocent yeah i just yeah i see
you wanting to teach i think i thought
about being a teacher at one point okay
rock star life's i don't know like i
don't know for some reason as a kid yeah
like i want to grow up and be a rock
star and be like on stage and sing and
be in a band of stars and glitz and i
don't know why
but i just i i see a little gestures
watching tv and seeing all these bands
and just like yeah
i picture her organizing things and like
it's crazy i looked at you and saw
glasses like i for some reason was
looking at you as soon as you asked that
question i was like teacher she that's
weird so you think i have some sort of
like a
caretaker motherly vibe because i like
entirely barren in my soul
that is not true which makes the best
teachers because i don't really know any
teachers that gave a [ __ ]
they did and then like life happened you
know what i mean they're like i gotta be
in this [ __ ]
like attached because then if your
students [ __ ] up and you personally but
there's always that teacher like yeah
you probably really wanted to help
people and then you realize that this
ain't [ __ ] yeah and the money ain't good
and now your school system is absolutely
terrible and now you're mad she's at
school and she's tosses if you're jolly
ranchers yeah there's a [ __ ] apple
yeah here so learn what the [ __ ] is two
plus two
that's still no two plus two come on
tommy like you really it's out of pocket
cause what's happening here who dressed
you today yeah just damn why are you
still his food
why don't i see you like i'm just gonna
everybody take recess yeah
um knowing you though you know you say i
called dark soul and stuff but it's
funny because even if you are like i
don't care i don't even like you these
people i don't like nothing i'm not i'm
not even here anymore you still will
make sure everything's taken care of
like you'll still be like all right so i
prepared these uh we were gonna do this
and like we're the day's gonna go like
this i think we got this we got it it's
gonna it's handled you'll still make
sure everybody's got their snacks and
everything things packed and ready to go
even if you're like i don't care it
hurts me i hate these people
they'll still make sure it's taken care
of yeah yeah that's the bible what did
you want to be uh a doctor oh i could
see that yeah mm-hmm
what kind of doctor
i don't know just a doctor pediatrics
just to have didn't know
and helping people yeah yeah but then
the reality of being a doctor is really
disgusting yes long hours
but just dealing with people's bodies
gross right absolutely gross no i'm
curious what did you want to be you two
an actor oh well there you go yeah
i always wanted to be like a model and a
food critic oh yeah and so now we've
combined the two yeah
i was thinking though if
if podcasting or youtuber or something
like that this world existed when i was
a kid i might have picked it yeah yeah
it just wasn't around so like actor was
the closest because i love
like i love performing in general
entertaining
and then um i love like learning about
people like i love like the psychology
behind like why do you act like you like
why is this person like this and like
kind of trying it on and being like
could i be like that is that like me
like and kind of exploring that i like
that stuff yeah i want to give you a
model and an astronaut
astronaut there's something about girls
that want to model it's like i want a
model but then i have more to me
i'm pretty but i want to go to the moon
but then i got carsick and then that
killed my dream yeah
i could never you can't even never do an
uber yeah to the space station you can't
even make it there
what made me pick astronauts yeah what
made you pick it uh when i saw my first
meteor shower when i was in seventh
grade
space is just cool it is really cool
i picked it because berenstein bears um
went to the moon and they um when they
jump they're like it
but then brandon morris who was in the
third grade when i was first grade i
didn't want to be an astronaut he told
me that sometimes they run out of oxygen
up there and they'll die okay and i was
like
oh god
yeah dude is it my turn who's next is it
me
okay
do you think i'm usually early
on time or late to events explain early
or on time for sure
why just based on the couple of times
we've had basically looking somewhere
like some looking late late pretty girls
are always late
oh yeah
yeah and like a lady of leisure yeah
like she shows up when she wants to show
up and it doesn't the party doesn't
start till she shows up everyone else is
just early based on looks yeah but it's
so hard now like knowing her i'm like
she's on top of her [ __ ] yeah
i don't think you would appreciate
someone being even five minutes late
[ __ ] can't stand you have you always
been your time
established through oh yeah sports okay
yeah
you gotta be on time there's punishments
for being late then there was a period
where i was like
i'm not showing up till i feel like
showing up because the party doesn't
start until i walk in literally it's
very dependent on the event you're
showing up to work yeah i
get anxiety yes i i get anxiety about
being late but again that just goes back
to growing up and playing sports it's
like you've got to be on time there are
consequences and when there's
consequences to your action it gets
drilled into you the first time you have
to like run suicides because you were
like a minute late
never again never again and i i was such
a rule follower growing up and then when
i no longer had to worry about answering
to like my parents or to my dad mainly
i rebelled like i was like i ain't doing
[ __ ] like i didn't i used to have to do
all the chores all the like everything
and then there was a period i was like i
ain't doing [ __ ] like you can't tell me
to do nothing i'ma show up when i want
to show up like you can't tell me what
to do but now i'm kind of back to the
balance like all right it's work mode
when it's work nikki
on time i try to be like you know at
least five to ten minutes early
i probably like the last one to leave i
want to make sure everything is good and
taken care of and i absolutely despise
and my friends do this sometimes i don't
care if we're just meeting to go to
dinner
don't [ __ ] waste my time yeah it is
the worst because if i had to book a
reservation
and i had to go out of my way to make
sure that i'm here on time and you're
late like you're disrespecting me and i
can understand if there's other stuff
going on but stop yelling at gina i
don't know i'm just trying to cry i want
you to love me
you would hate me i would
i would schedule around you i feel like
i would say eight o'clock but it's
really 8 30. that's what my friends do
and i've done that to some of my friends
you changed the call time by an hour for
her specifically like no one's saying
anything just yeah give her an earlier
position and don't say it don't get
insane modern problems yeah require
modern solutions
but now she has to show up for work and
it's like but it would be like but
here's the thing if i change the time
and then you're still late oh yeah i
would be so dis i would be like
disappointed if you because i might
already express that like you're better
at it though since you've had your nine
to five job yeah you've learned a little
bit more sometimes you're better
within the last few years i used to be
bad tiff knows yeah or just not even
show up at all
there's something about showing up late
and you know
it's like the wrong type of attention
yeah unless it's the certain settings
right like you know if it's a party and
you're at a party parties it's fine
party is different but yeah
you're sitting there everybody's like oh
[ __ ] nikki's late again yeah and then
fall production all of a sudden there's
like a bunch of other [ __ ] wrong with
you it's like oh she's never on time and
she this [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like an
extra thing ugly yeah like she ain't
[ __ ] but she don't even smell that good
but definitely working i smell great uh
but working production is like i i get
so much more anxious about it now
because it's not just
you know just showing up to dinner
you're like everyone's eating already
now it's like oh a whole production is
getting held up for me especially now at
g4 yeah yeah terrified and that's money
yeah that's money i think you might be
scared into being on time yeah
you gotta be scared into like everything
everyone has like that one traumatic
event that happened that made you follow
some sort of rule because my dad was
military like he was from a military
family and it was very like on time is
late early's on time like that kind of
[ __ ] and like he would yell at me if i
was even like a second late or if i was
exactly on time i would get yelled at
like it was just like brutal so i where
i get anxiety yeah i'm like late because
i'm like i'm going to be in trouble i'm
going to know that even if it's not like
real it's like in my head i'm getting
yelled at and it's just like and the
reasons that i'm is like you're
disrespectful and blah blah blah and i'm
like i'm being disrespectful
but my family now they know i show up
when i show up like now there's certain
things i'm like yeah this ain't work
like i love y'all you're gonna get me
when i'm ready to deal with y'all yeah
it's like i'm glad it was great
ingrained for work right but but now i'm
like personal [ __ ] you i i i live here i
don't like [ __ ] anyways i'm sitting on
the couch watching tv i didn't miss
nothing call me when the food is ready
yeah
sometimes my dad will text me like where
are you because it's like three three or
four minutes after the things started
it's like a family like people are just
[ __ ] talking and eating oh and [ __ ]
and i'm just like there yet right we're
asian we show up
it's more of like when are we leaving
yeah it doesn't matter when we show up
because we're going to be there it's
more like when the [ __ ] are you leaving
my house yeah
but there's pillows because you're
probably going to stay yeah but it does
give you like that little bit of
rebellious like i haven't left yet
i love it
again just go against my family
sometimes i show up late because y'all
made me show up you can skip that one if
you want because it's probably one of
the last okay find one that you like if
everybody was to look at each other and
assume yeah everyone's favorite color
what would it be
what do you think my favorite color is
teal or purple okay what do you think my
favorite color is um
brown because you look good brown
yeah i think you like poo-poo
see i was thinking that i think it's the
outfit that's throwing me yeah
that
yeah
jess looks like her favorite color is
navy blue tomatoes oh my god that's true
yeah
yeah yeah
paint in the kitchen that color you
like the color green well my last name's
green well nowadays i do like green but
it's more of a darker green though right
like yeah like an emerald emerald green
my favorite color i've always said pink
but honestly to wear has always been
like orange colors orange peachy orange
colors you look good in it thank you
yeah what color would i you guys think i
would like black yeah
black void yeah just like unanimously
right you wear color because you don't
like color for some reason this is
nikki's shirt yeah any color that you
see
into my car wearing these yeah
clothes every shoot
they don't have to breathe
and i don't bring any clothes what kind
of music do you guys think each person
i already know that we already know
that's true but then gasolina all like
it was like gasoline
i want to live die married get [ __ ]
buried by gasoline forever we're gonna
walk down the aisle again
yeah
i want him there at my wedding
officiating me i feel like you dress
like you listen to edm
it's true like you know what i mean like
that's you scream i like yeah what i was
going to say about the color thing too
is like i feel like it's like black so
that neon pops off of yeah it's like you
would want neon around you
[Applause]
um
and
jess what would jessica say why i i'm
going to say this i i love you but i'm
just going to be that [ __ ] right now
you look like you listen to elevator
music
like she's
yeah like when you're in the elevator
you purposely want to go to the top
floor just to listen to that you can
just hear the symbols
i don't know why but it's funny this is
like elevator music like i look [ __ ]
expensive though right now
like it's a nordstrom elevator right
yeah
yeah and then she goes and rides the
elevator back
this is where i stay there
right yeah that's your zone that's your
space everything else annoys you yes
beneath you yeah
i mean you're breathing a little bit
loud right now
i'm so sorry that was for gina would it
be
would it be
would it be racist it's funny to say oh
right for me to say like keith urban oh
yes
no it wasn't it doesn't make sense
pigtails yeah only because that name
just sticks out because i just saw a
tick tock with keith urban yesterday
that's all okay what do i look like i
feel like hip hop when i see you but i
don't know if it's just because like
i picture you because i'm brown no i
picture you in like a nice ass car no
like a picture of you because you look
like a video gamer
like
i can say that i'm gonna do it you know
i picture you like in a nice ass luxury
vehicle like an escalade or something
but it's like like tinted windows it's
rolling down but hip-hop music is
playing and like maybe something we want
to smoke is coming out more r b video
like you're the
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's leaving because
you cheated and you like got the nails
yeah you're like oh you know what you're
not video vixen twerking you are no more
like mary j blige like i just hear
harder than that
hey ladies when your man wanna oh yeah
that's you yeah with like all the rich
everything and the
and fur coats and i love y'all yes
that's it
for a coat and then but also like a lot
of a lot of um
megan the stallion on the side yeah yeah
you know
like i definitely am on my thought [ __ ]
thank god
yeah city girl's a little bit yeah throw
some city girls in there
you know what i'm giving everything else
good i'm not giving what i want to be
giving but it's okay yeah
you know what the elevator of music is
actually you're not trying to give
elevators
i'm getting a check to look like a baby
mind you you're not even wearing your
own clothes i'm not putting it
[Laughter]
looks do i intimidate you yes or no
off looks yeah
with that face yes but when you smile no
no even even probably you at your like
hardest for me like no well i mean like
you tower over me and you're stunning so
like what am i gonna do punch at your
[ __ ] ankles like before you open your
mouth on your instagram yes yeah but
then when as soon as i met you like
within the first second it's like oh my
gosh she's so nice like
so like i yeah no i think because we
come from the same like world it's like
nah yeah
i think yes but more so not i don't know
the intimidation for me would be like
you just seem like you don't give a [ __ ]
so like i would be
hurt because like i would like not be
cool enough for you to give a [ __ ] about
not like yeah i'm scared of you or like
you're better than me but like oh she's
not gonna care oh
but i want her to be investigating she
probably won't care about me i feel like
you would probably need to give a [ __ ]
if i was to just look at jess i would
say out of everybody here you look the
most intimidating yeah that's true
mm-hmm i would i would find you
intimidating again it goes to the like i
don't like into the dna kind of thing
but i feel like i would have to
but i feel like i would have to like
work like work to make you like me like
i feel like if that's what in mind you
look like you're analyzing a lot yeah so
it's like what's she you make me feel
what you're thinking about yeah you make
me question myself dang i have heard
that from even guys dating they're like
i can't read what's in your head at all
right now that's also what i like too
yeah i don't know i don't know what i'm
doing i don't know what else to do with
my face
nikki's the least
intimidating looking yeah even like your
straight face is still like really like
i'd say i probably put that vibe out too
like i don't want anyone to be
intimidated by me first meeting nikki
i'm like i need to protect you
yeah i just want to cuddle you i think
when people tell me that because people
have told me that i look intimidating
but i think it's more so how i dress
usually because i feel like my clothing
might look intimidating but my cheeks
give it away yeah
yeah when you just smile a little bit
your eyes turn into half yeah yeah like
like you smile [ __ ] anime face
that's like going back to like the
popular thing i'm like i wanna hang out
with you you give me like oh we're gonna
have so much yeah the other day you were
just like you were just resting face and
your eyes looked like anime eyes like
the with the little dots like i'm like
how does she always have a perfect like
slit like a glare what's it called like
the little glitter
the shimmer on your eyes i think with
nikki i want to protect you
you if i walk into a room like i want to
get to know her because she seems fun
and then you i feel like when i look at
you i'm like
i want to learn everything from you
like yeah i just i wanted to learn
everything from you about you like
you're a weirdo because you don't you
don't like you know what you know what
it is
you look like someone that doesn't
really let people know who you are
unless they really ask the right
questions and you don't just uh give
information
so i just want to ask all the questions
and know everything about you because
i'm so [ __ ] curious about you
so if jess was a man you'd date her oh
yeah are you saying you'd [ __ ] me you're
mysterious she's mysterious
oh yeah she's a mysterious one well then
what do you think i don't know do i i
don't know what i don't know what how
would i give off i guess necessarily
i've heard that the only thing that has
been constant is i can't read you i
can't read which in your head yeah like
there's a lot in there but i don't know
i don't know how i should come off like
if that's a bad thing or if it's a good
thing
no no it's just like it's you it's like
yeah that's your essence is like you
have a mystery i am always observing
and like categorizing and count like
[ __ ] like thinking i'm like okay like
this makes this this is like i am kind
of always kind of like i love you it's
running it's always running i i love you
and introducing you new people because i
feel like we have to earn you
like i've introduced you some friends
before and then they'll be like jess is
really like intense and like you know
like
she's she seems like kind of a [ __ ] i'm
like
just give it up just give it a few more
seconds yeah just warm up yeah and then
you'll see and then afterwards they're
like dude she's [ __ ] red yeah yeah
yeah we could talk about this forever
but yeah we will because gina has the
actual card game and we'll play it yeah
we could play again for sure um let us
know in the comments like what you would
have thought just based off of
appearances and if they're if they're
similar if they're way different and
pick up the gate or check the game out
we're not sponsored by them but like
we're not really strangers they're
they're great at getting the
conversation going and digging daily
strangers either certainly not we're
about to not be strangers pretty soon i
want to be part of this party
you're a little far subscribe go find
nicki on a no chaser nikki street eats
big uh big bay mornings
superb sportswear check it out we got
sneakers i'm coming out with my own
fitness line with them we got sweaters
like
there's a lot going on so we got superb
sportswear you can check me out no
chaser podcast nikki streets on
instagram nikki blaze on instagram and
monday through friday from 6 a.m to 10
a.m on 99 7 now for big bay mornings
give her all your goodies give her
something i'll give you a list go do it
that's an itinerary to do list complete
at least one send her all your credit
card numbers
cash out dollar sign nicky blades there
you go accepting bitcoin and ethereum
thank you
bye guys love you bye
[Music]
you